you have to have a plan you have to have
a strategy and then you have to have
stick-to-it-ness because you know that
the strategy is not going to immediately
bear fruit the American character is one
that lurches between spasm and trance we
get real exercise for about two weeks
and then we fall asleep for two years
our vision extends decades extends
generations if we set the trend lines
just a little bit better then the infant
that's crying in Compton or Harlem or
Anacostia or the Ninth Ward that infant
may have a different future and then
when that infant has a different future
the country has a different future and
then we as a people have a different
future so there's got to be an
understanding of how time can actually
help us move mountains if we're working
with time we're not waiting for time
we're working with them you may have
setbacks and you may have failures but
you're not done you're not even getting
started not by a long shot
and if you ever forget that just look to
history Thomas Paine was a failed corset
maker a failed teacher and a failed tax
collector before he made his mark on
history with a low book called common
sense that helped ignite a revolution
Julia Child didn't publish her first
cookbook until she was almost 50 Colonel
Sanders didn't open up his first
Kentucky Fried Chicken until he was in
the sixties Winston Churchill was
dismissed as little more than a has-been
who enjoyed scotch a little bit too much
before he took over as prime minister
and saw Great Britain through its finest
hour your body of work is never done
each of them at one point in their life
didn't have any title or much status to
speaker
but they have passion a commitment to
following that passion wherever would
lead and are working hard every step
along the way you just watched two
amazing clips from Barack Obama take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]